a British anti-islam commentator gets
arrested the media claimed the president
Trump is out to get immigrant children
and Louis Farrakhan makes him
weirdly pro Trump noises I'm Ben Shapiro
this is the Ben Shapiro show
I hope you had a wonderful Memorial Day
weekend I hope you took a few moments
out yesterday to pay tribute to our
fallen troops who have died so that we
can be here doing all sorts of fun
things and exercising our American
liberties but I have a lot to get to
today in the news and before we get to
any of that I first want to say thanks
to our sponsors over at man Crais now
you've heard me talk about man crates
before man crates is the best gift a
dude can get because here's the problem
with Father's Day dad isn't gonna tell
you what to get them and you're gonna
get them the same gift every year it's
gonna be a crappy mug that you made at
some sort of
pottery shop well don't do that instead
go over to man crates what what exactly
are man crates will they're hand-picked
and packaged gifts for every type of dad
they've the knife making kit for the
hands-on dad or the whiskey appreciation
kit for dads who like the finer things
or just don't want to deal with you
today most gifts ship in a sealed wooden
crate with a crowbar
so yeah sure you get to pry the man
crate open with your manly muscles in
front of everyone
when's the last time you gave your dad a
gift he needed a crowbar to open it is a
thing for men and with man crates you're
giving to have more than a gift you're
giving him a gift experience it really
is very cool they have all sorts of
different gifts I have the poker set one
day I will make friends and then we will
play with the poker set that I got from
man crate sometime in the future
it came in ammo can it really is super
cool man crates come with a 100%
satisfaction guarantee and get your
special Father's Day discount today at
man crates calm slash Ben it's a limited
time offer only for Father's Day go
today that's man crates calm slash Ben
use that slash Ben so we know they said
so they know we sent you man crates calm
/ban all right so there's a lot of news
breaking today but the big news over the
weekend is one that is going oddly
unnoticed by the mainstream media that
of course is the arrest of a alt-right
far-right activist named Tommy Robinson
who is reportedly jailed after filming
outside of a child grooming trial in
Britain so Tommy Robinson's very
controversial figure it's hard to figure
out exactly where he stands he's sort of
on the fringes of the right he was the X
founder of the English Defence League
he's been arrested in the past for some
violent run-ins with with the police
he's been at rallies that involve
anti-semites but now he is pro-israel so
he's sort of all over the place a little
bit and he's made some comments that are
actually particularly egregious in the
past he's blamed all Muslims for
terrorists for terrorist attacks etc
but one thing that he's been doing
lately is backed off of some of those
comments and one thing he's been doing
lately is he's been going outside of
these grooming trials in Britain so for
people who haven't been following this
there's been a series of scandals in
Britain where it turns out that there
were Muslim men radical Muslims
religious Muslims who were who were
apparently grooming young children to be
essentially gang raped in a couple of
locations in Britain and these were
largely covered up by the local police
we've talked about a little bit on the
show before they were covered up by
local police or at least they weren't
fully investigated by local police the
press refused to cover them because they
were afraid of the anti Islamic backlash
they were afraid would ensue well here
is what happened this guy Tommy Robinson
who again is a kooky fellow he sort of
milo gianopolous Lite he was arrested
and reportedly jailed on Friday after he
filmed members of an alleged child
grooming gang entering a court for trial
so he was standing outside he was
filming them apparently in Britain
you're not allowed to do this because
they are afraid that it will bias the
jurors if you actually film people
outside so here is video of him being
arrested for literally standing outside
of a court and holding a cell phone in
fact someone later handed us on the
outside me about my mother and Here I am
being arrested for say nothing so the
judges in the past have arrested him
before he was arrested
hanging a year ago in a similar case
where he was filming outside of a
courthouse in Leeds he apparently went
into the courthouse in this case he
didn't go inside the courthouse the
judge in that case said that Tommy
Robinson could have been responsible for
biasing the jurors now think about this
from an American perspective the press
are constantly going to courthouses and
filming outside courthouses as
defendants walk in there were all sorts
of pictures just last week of Harvey
Weinstein walking into a police station
being arrested walking out there was no
suggestion that all of the media who are
reporting Harvey Weinstein's arrest were
somehow contributing to an atmosphere of
say anti-semitism why because that's
idiotic it's insane to say that you
can't report on trials it's ridiculous
to suggest you can't say things that
obviously are public import in matters
concern
in some cases what appears to be a
guarded culture of the police protecting
certain people in order to prevent
Islamophobia or whatever this is well
here is what gets even crazier about the
story so Tommy Robinson is arrested and
then an order comes down from the court
it's now been reversed but the original
order from the court was you were not
allowed to report on Tommy Robinson's
arrest because if you reported on Tommy
Robinson's arrest then you'd be biasing
the jurors in his case ok well this
doesn't sound like V for Vendetta kind
of stuff I don't know what does this
sort of weirdly dystopian nonsense where
you can't report on a trial because it
involves radical Muslims who are
allegedly raping children and then if
you do report and you are arrested then
we can't report on your arrest because
then that might bias the jurors in your
case so according to a source to talk to
Fox News they say the time Robinson was
jailed in hoe prison the prison declined
to comment to Fox News on whether
Robinson was there Leeds Crown Court
also did not return a quest for
information according to the independent
Robinson was already on a suspended
sentence for contempt of court over a
gang rape case in 2017 the judge in the
case on Friday slapped a reporting ban
on the case again this is something that
only happens in Britain we don't have
this sort of thing in the United States
there bans on having reporters inside
courtrooms sometimes sometimes they
won't allow cameras in the courtroom but
there is no idea that you can't report
on a case okay in the United States
everyone can report on a case so long as
the courtroom isn't closed and you can
report what's going on outside the
courtroom well the judge in the case
slapped a reporting ban on the case the
order bans reporters from reporting on a
case if there is reason to believe the
reporting could prejudice a trial
there's had a vague and insane that
standard is that if you believe the
reporting could prejudice a trial you
can't report on it every report could
possibly affect a trial every single
report and you report about anything
going on in the world could
theoretically impact a trial it's one of
the reasons why in the United States we
often have jury sequestration were in
the OJ case for example you put up
people at a particular hotel and then
you cut out the cable so that's
presumably they're not supposed to get
any sort of information from the outside
I have serious questions as to whether
even that is constitutional but at least
in the United States there's no ban on
the reporting there are restrictions on
the jurors as to what they can see but
it isn't that CNN or MSNBC or Fox News
can't report on a given trial
that's insane so what happened a bunch
of news outlets in the UK removed their
reporting from their websites to comply
with the gag order
most remaining reporting in the UK
comments
Robinson's arrest but not on his
purported sentencing sources with
knowledge of Robinson's case spoke on
condition of anonymity in part because
if you're that they would then be
arrested for contempt well remember this
is the country of Magna Carta this is
the country of Edmund Burke this is the
country of John Locke is the country
where Liberty of speech where Liberty of
thought was born and now we were being
told he can't even report on cases in
Britain if it should by his people if it
should bias the jurors one of these
sources told Fox that Tommy Robinson's
lawyer warned that considering the
presence of Muslim gang members in
prison a 13-month sentence was
tantamount to a death sentence Tommy's
lawyer said he will likely die in jail
given his profile on previous credible
threats the judge basically said he
doesn't care the source said he
sentenced him to 13 months in prison but
we don't have that confirmed but there's
no way to confirm it because we can't
report on it so who knows what's been
said at this point it is certainly true
that Tommy Robinson has had run-ins with
Muslims before he was jailed for a for a
brief period of time a few years back
and he lost all of his front teeth in a
brawl apparently allegedly with some
Muslim prisoners hey so it's good to
know that Britain is really concerned
with the values that bore Britain rather
the the fascists and the fascism that
that Britain fought for decades it
hasn't won in any way it's just that
Britain has now voluntarily condemning
its own citizens to be jailed for
reporting on cases and if your report on
the report then all of a sudden you're
in even more trouble but here's the good
news the good news is that Britain
really has its priorities straight
because at the same time they're
preventing Tommy Robinson from actually
reporting on these cases and then
preventing people from reporting on the
table in Robinson case at least Ireland
has voted to go full ahead with with
allowing abortion up to the 20th week so
there was a a massive there was a
massive referendum passed two to one in
Ireland to get rid of the country's
abortion ban so they had a ban on
abortion that went all the way back to
inception because there was a right to
life to consumption there was a right to
life in the Irish Constitution right
said I think it was section 8 article 8
of the of the Irish Constitution that
says that there's a right to life that
extends to the unborn
well that was done away with over the
weekend in a massive procession the the
Irish people came out and they stood in
front of that they stood in front of the
Prime Minister's office and here's a
picture of the prime minister of Ireland
celebrating along with these thousands
of people out there in the street
it's just supposed to be amazing he
tweeted it out and and what he said was
that this was just an incredible crowd
he took our fantastic crowds at Dublin
Castle a remarkable day a quiet
revolution has taken place a great act
of democracy so let's be straight about
this the great act of democracy is
allowing the unborn to be killed in the
womb the great act of democracy is not
protecting people reporting on trials
okay this is not this is the end of
Western civilization I mean this really
is the suicide the slow suicide of
Western civilization Western
civilization European civilization the
land on which individual rights were
born okay those are those rights are now
being killed
piece by piece they're being destroyed
piece by piece they're being carved up
and buried piece by piece you may not
like Tommy Robinson you may think he's a
schmuck I think he sort of is but that
doesn't make a difference
what the time he Robinson case shows you
is that Europe's idea of its own rights
they've been completely overturned
they've been completely overthrown
instead it's tolerance and
multiculturalism and diversity that
matters it's protection of feelings not
protection of rights the unborn they can
be killed on mass and you will have
hundreds of thousands of people in the
streets celebrating but if a guy gets
arrested for covering a trial there's
only a couple of hundred protesters
outside Parliament yeah that says
something about the state of Western
civilization and it's not pretty
in other good news at least the EU is
proposing banning all sorts of plastic
products that's also deeply important
the EU has proposed banning plastic
products like comment and the cotton
buds straws stirs and balloon sticks
when alternatives are easily available
in an attempt to reduce litter spoiling
beaches and ocean beds the European
Commission said its proposal would seek
to cut marine litter in half of the ten
for the ten most prominent items and
avoid environmental damage estimated at
over 250 billion dollars over the next
dozen years so it's good the EU is right
on top of the stuff the EU can't prevent
mass Muslim migration from the Middle
East unvetted they can't prevent that
but they can't prevent you from using a
drinking straw so we know that their
priorities are definitely on or over in
Europe there's nothing to worry about
it's amazing Europe has seen this
upswing and this real upsurge in
right-wing sentiments and it's reflected
as this ultra nationalist sentiment is a
sentiment that makes me deeply
uncomfortable right you're seeing a lot
of far-right parties in places like
Poland and Hungary that are suddenly
beginning to see all sorts of support
you're seeing it in Britain as well that
is a reaction it is a reaction you don't
like it I don't like it a lot of people
don't like it
but to pretend that it is not a reaction
to a left that is gone completely
overboard in favor of transnational
institutions destroying individual
rights is to pretend that what is
happening is not happening okay they're
a bunch of people out there and their
response to this shouldn't be sort of
this ethno nationalist let's all get
together and ban the foreigners kind of
stuff what it should be is the only way
we can protect individual rights is with
a nationalism that suggests that we have
something to stand for and unfortunately
that's not what's happened instead what
you've gotten is the far left that's
taken over the EU which it always was
going to and it's taken over government
in Britain which it apparently was
always going to and then you've seen a
nationalist right in response this is
what makes American conservatism so
different there's no such thing as
American conservatism in Europe this is
why whenever you have discussions about
the Nazis what people tend to say on the
left is they say well they're a
right-wing group and when people on the
right will say oh no they're a left-wing
group and the truth is that by American
standards they're a left-wing group okay
the Nazis were a group of big government
fascists who wanted the government
controlling every aspect of American
life which sounds a lot more like the
American Left than like the American
right but in but in Europe the Nazis
were right-wing because they were
anti-communist there is no such thing as
an individual right States primarily in
Europe it doesn't exist anymore Britain
was the closest thing to it and Britain
has overthrown that Britain has thrown
that out America is the best of the
rights regime that that the Europeans
were supposedly the originators of and
now the Europeans have decided to do
away with that in the name of tolerance
and diversity and multiculturalism a few
years back it looked like the Europeans
were finally going to rebell in the
proper way against this David Cameron
gave a big speech about how
multiculturalism was a giant fail I mean
even Angela Merkel came out and said
multiculturalism was a giant fail but
just because they said it publicly
didn't mean they felt it privately or
that they were going to implement
policies that protected individual
rights that only come from a particular
civilization one of the great lies
that's been told by members of the
international left by a lot of folks in
Europe by a lot of folks on the American
left is that individual rights just
inherently crop up that they are
self-evident that they are not the
products of any sort of civilization and
so you can get rid of all of the
cultural hallmarks of a civilization you
can embrace multiculturalism but keep
the rights that's not how it works
if you want to embrace multiculturalism
that means that you are inevitably going
to be embracing cultures that do not
value particularly the rights that you
created have a little bit more on this
but first I want to say thanks towards
sponsors over at ring so rings mission
is to make neighborhoods safer and they
are doing it every day because today
over a million people use the amazing
ring video doorbell to help protect
their homes ring nose home security
begins at the front door it does not end
there
so now they are extending that same
level of security to the rest of your
home with ring floodlight cam we have
ring at our house by the way it is just
great it means that when I am 3,000
miles away
I can still check to see who's ringing
the doorbell because a lot of burglaries
happen in daytime somebody rings the
doorbell sees if you're home if you're
not then they rob the place well if they
ring the doorbell I can pick up no
matter where I am I can see who is there
and now ring has the ring flood like him
just like rings amazing doorbell flood
like Hammonds motion-activated camera
and floodlight it connects right to your
phone with HD video two-way audio lets
you know the moment anyone steps on your
property so you can see them you can
talk to them you can warn them you can
sound an alarm it's really great with
rings floodlight cam when things go bump
in the night you will immediately know
what it is whether you're home or away
the ring floodlight cam lets you keep an
eye on your house ring floodlight cam
offers the ultimate in home security
again those high visibility floodlights
powerful HD camera with ring you're
always at home and right now you can
save up to one hundred and fifty bucks
off that ring of security kit when you
go to rings comm slash Ben that's ring
comm slash Ben again ring that calm /
Ben when you use that / Benny get 150
bucks off your ring of security kit and
you also let them know and that we sent
you hey the real question is what sort
of values must once again crop up in
Europe to protect the rights that were
born in Europe and the answer is pride
in a civilization not pride in ethnicity
not pride in the borders of a nation not
pride even in a quote unquote common
culture the culture of Liberty is the
culture that should be instilled ok the
West Western civilization is considered
a civilization because of its Creed and
its Creed was individual rights trumped
communal rights that didn't hold true in
a lot of the European countries like
France the French Revolution versus the
American Revolution the American
Revolution was about the individual over
the community have you read the
Constitution of the United States he
talks about We the People instituting a
government in order to protect our
individual rights and then there's Bill
of Rights that specifically applies to
individuals and then there's the French
Declaration of the Rights of Man which
suggested the opposite it suggested that
communal rights Trump the individual it
says that any time an individual right
comes into conflict with the community
the community wins
well Britain used to be very much
against the French Revolution a Edmund
Burke who's the great
of conservatism embraced by so many
conservatives today Russell Kirk great
American author wrote about the impact
of Burke on American conservatism and
that's because what Edmund Burke said is
that the French Revolution took all of
the cultural hallmarks they took Church
they took religion they took culture
they took history and they threw all of
them out in favor of this newfangled
idea of rights and what Edmund Burke
said is that the rights that we
currently have are a product of a
civilization that goes back thousands of
years and to reject that premise is to
reject the rights themselves well Europe
has now fallen under the French
revolutionaries one hey the French
revolutionaries chopped off a lot of
heads and it seemed like they'd fallen
but in the end they won hey in the end
the French one and the Burkean the
Burkean conservatism the Lockean
conservatism lost hey Burke and Locke
were both religious Christians and there
were both believers that there had to be
a culture a civilization of Liberty in
order for Liberty to mean anything the
French didn't believe that they believed
you could completely level everything
and get rid of the entire culture and
instead you can build up the system of
Rights which in the end would be
protected by a community and the
community in the end would also be able
to Trump the individual well Britain has
fallen to that now it is not a
coincidence that as church attendance
has declined in Britain you've seen the
rise of a multicultural ethos that ends
in the arrest of British citizens for
reporting on trials and gives the
go-ahead to abortion hey that is not a
coincidence you do need a certain
foundation in order for that edifice of
values to stand and that edifice of
values is obviously crumbling in Europe
and so you have to wonder why did it
crumble and the answer is pretty obvious
I know it's not popular I know a lot of
people don't want to hear maybe you
ought to look at your church maybe you
ought to look back to God maybe you
ought to look back to founding values in
the United States which were reliance on
the idea of Providence of divine eternal
Providence who provided for individual
rights I know that's uncomfortable stuff
and people would prefer to go with all
of these vague answers about rights
existing in some sort of weird sphere
without any sort of judeo-christian
history to them you get rid of the
judeo-christian history the rights go
along with them yeah it's just the way
that it works and Europe is finding that
out there pretends that it can maintain
the rights without maintaining the
history that just it's not working it's
not working and so you get yes yes on
abortion and no uncovering trials in the
same weekend in Great Britain one time
the only defender of civilization in the
Western world so
it's it's it's really a sad thing and I
think that it is something deeply worth
morning okay meanwhile I have to comment
on something that happened over the
weekend with with with the left and
immigration because it's utterly insane
so over the weekend the left decided
that Donald Trump was solely responsible
for the separation of parents from
children at the border so first I want
to set for you the legal standard
because you're hearing a lot of crap
today you're hearing a lot of nonsense
today that is just not true it's why
you're hearing today is that Donald
Trump Evo president Trump has decided in
his nefarious fashion because he hates
Mexicans cuz he thinks they're all
rapists that when people come to the
border than what he's going to do is
he's going to take their children and
rip them away from their parents and
he's going to send them to the salt
mines or some such nonsense
okay the reality is that by law by law
all detainees all miner detainees in the
United States must be must be remanded
out of custody to somebody else within
20 days this has been the law in the
United States for approximately the last
20 years 21 years there was a settlement
in 1997 is called the Flores settlement
it happened under the auspices of
President Bill Clinton okay and in that
settlement it found that settlement said
that unaccompanied minors is
specifically about unaccompanied minors
and it said unaccompanied minors to the
United States people come to the United
States and they're not accompanied by a
parent they cannot be held in detainment
facilities instead they have to be
released to foster care or they have to
be released to some sort of relative we
can track down okay that was the Flores
settlement in 1997 it did not apply to
accompanied minors so if a parent came
with their kid then there was no legal
obligation under the 1997 Flores
agreement that you have to take the kid
out of custody and give the kid to an
uncle or an aunt
instead the kid could stay in custody
with the parent until there was a
settlement
okay this settlement took place in two
with it well actually until there was a
Yazzie was it it was a piece of
legislation in 2008 and then it was
reinsuring in 2016 the Ninth Circuit
Court of Appeals ruled in 2016 in an
opinion by Judge Hurwitz okay Andrew
Hurwitz they ruled that the settlement
the 1997 1997 settlement agreement did
not only apply to unaccompanied minors
you could enroll them in custody it also
applied to accompany minors in other
words if I came
my four-year-old daughter and we were
Mexican immigrants illegal immigrants we
cross the border illegally and when I
was arrested under the old law we could
be held together in custody because
she's my four year old under the new law
under the settlement agreement the idea
was that my four-year-old daughter was
not best off in custody with me she was
best off being remanded to Aunt Martha
in in Texaco right and then we're going
to send and we're gonna send Aunt Martha
to wherever with the kid okay that was
the law this is what it says in that in
that court decision from the Ninth
Circuit 2016 quote the panel held that
the settlement unambiguously applies
both to minors who are accompanied and
unaccompanied by their parents the panel
tell however the district court erred in
interpreting the settlement to provide
release rights to accompanying adults so
didn't mean that you had to release the
adult right so this is what the Ninth
Circuit ruled the Ninth Circuit says you
do not have to release the adults but
you do have to release the kids well
what that means practically speaking is
that after 20 days the kids have to be
released so if you want to arrest the
adults then the adults have to remain in
custody and the kids have to be released
is that Donald Trump's fault no that's
been the law since before Donald Trump
was president has been the law for a
long time it's been the law since Obama
was president and the 1997 settlement
agreement was put into law
20 years ago so why exactly are people
saying that Donald Trump is the guy
who's running around internment
facilities ripping children away from
parents and handing them out to the
nearest passers-by it's just not true
it's just not true now what's more
astonishing is all the members of the
left who've decided to to make an issue
of this and decided that really is all
Trump's fault so to show you this okay I
just have to I have to give you some of
these sweets so Jon Favreau hey one of
the pods have america bros jon favreau
was a member of the obama administration
he served in the Obama administration
there's a picture from 2014 that was
going around of children in holding
facilities these children were
unaccompanied minors and they're put in
holding facilities in 2014 now you may
recall 2014 who was president was the
Trump no it was President Barack Obama
you remember that guy right he was
annoying you remember that guy well that
dude put all those kids in these holding
facilities Jon Favreau was working for
the administration or did work for the
administration he tweeted out the 2014
photos as though Donald Trump had put
these kids in the holding facilities
here's what he tweeted quote look at
these pictures
this is happening right now and the only
debate that matters is how we force our
government to get these kids back to
their families as fast as humanly
possible it's not just John Favreau
Shaun King tweeted the same thing Linda
Sarsour tweeted the same thing they all
treated out these pictures and they
pretended that they were all from 2018
when they were all from 2014 then they
found out they're from 2014 bunch of
these people started deleting their
tweets so Jon Favreau got rid of his
tweet because it turns out that it just
wasn't true all of which goes to show
you that something weird has happened to
members of the media and I have more to
talk about with regard to this weirdness
in just one second but first I want to
say thanks to our sponsors at Dollar
Shave Club so if you ever a shower or
brush your teeth or try to make your
hair look presentable like you're a
human well you need to talk to my
friends over at Dollar Shave Club Dollar
Shave Club delivers everything you need
to look feel and smell your best they
have everything you need to get ready in
the bathroom you can clear out all that
crap that she's been lying on your
counters instead just get Dollar Shave
Club products it is better ok Dollar
Shave Club delivers everything you need
a shampoo conditioner body wash
toothpaste hair gel
even that wipe that leaves your butt
feeling unbelievably clean just wildly
clean they have this actually fantastic
calming body cleanser now you may think
that Shapiro's you don't seem like a
calm guy you should see me before I use
the calming body cleanser ok there amber
and lavender a calming body cleanser
it's really excellent it smells
fantastic
all of Dollar Shave club's products are
made with top-shelf ingredients that
won't break your budget and you will
feel the difference plus shipping is
included with your membership here's a
great way to try a bunch of Dollar Shave
Club products for just 5 bucks you can
get their daily essentials starter set
and it comes with all of the
aforementioned wonderful products
including their best razor the 6 blade
executive keep the blades coming for a
few bucks more per month and you add in
shampoo toothpaste anything else you
need for the bathroom check it all out
at dollarshaveclub.com slash Ben that's
dollarshaveclub.com slash man when you
use that slash Ben they even get that
amazing way to try it out for 5 bucks
and get that daily essential starter set
and try it out again dollarshaveclub.com
slash Ben you're not gonna regret it it
cleans out your bathroom and all the
products are just fantastic so check it
out dollarshaveclub.com
let them know that we sent you alright
so in the media something has gone wrong
in their minds and I have proof of this
so if vodka Trump or she tweeted out
over the weekend she tweeted out a
picture of herself with her child
because it's Memorial Day weekend
and she has really cute kids and she
tweeted out a picture of her selves a
beautiful picture of her holding one of
her children and it says my love I love
Sunday morning okay and that's in it's
it's my love and I hashtag Sunday
morning and it's picture of her and one
of her babies and she's just looking the
baby's eyes CNN decides that this is
inappropriate if Uncle Trump cannot
tweet a picture of herself with her
child not well Donald Trump is whipping
immigrant children away from their
parents no he can't do that and she
can't do that
CNN actually did this okay I'm not
joking about this CNN actually for two
minutes and 30 seconds covered Ivanka
Trump's tweet and suggested she was a
bad person for tweeting out a picture
unrelated of her and her child it's
insane what's the timing of this tweet
that is really generating so much
criticism because it comes like you
mentioned amid scrutiny of the
administration's policies letting the
government separate children from their
parents at the border President Trump
himself was tweeting about it over the
weekend describing it as a horrible law
and it's not the first time that Ivanka
Trump has been accused of insensitivity
on social media recall for example in
January of last year right after her
father was inaugurated she posted a
picture of her and Jared Kushner and
fancy Black Tie attire right after her
father had signed that controversial
travel ban and there were chaos and
protests erupting at airports all over
the country she weathered similar
criticism and once again she's being
accused of being out of touch you have
got to be kidding me
it's Memorial Day weekend she was had a
picture of her and her baby and she's
evil now this really is do you remember
in the Wrath of Khan in the Wrath of
Khan you know one of the fam great
political movies of our time there was a
there's a scene very early on where an
earworm is put inside who is it check
off I think and I put an earworm and
check off the ear and the idea is that
these ear worm essentially controls his
brain Donald Trump is the ear worm for
some reason he's the ear worm in the
brain of the media and no matter what he
does
we wiggling around in there the media
just lose it because what in the world
does this picture of Ivanka Trump and
her beautiful kid have to do with
immigrant kids being separated from
their parents a policy that has been in
place in the United States since 2016 at
the behest of the leftist nine
Circuit Court of Appeals what in the
hell what in the hell and here's how
amazing the media are so you have all
these fact-checking sites
now all these fact-checking sets like
factcheck.org and PolitiFact and half of
their fact checks are just wrong half
their fact checks they legitimately draw
a conclusion that no one drew from an
original statement and then they say
that it's half true or not half true
based on whether it's a democrat or
republican you remember most famously
PolitiFact said that barack obama was
not lying when he said they said it was
half true and he said if you like your
doctor you can keep your doctor and then
three years later they labeled that same
exact statement their lie of the year
okay which is because they're full of it
because they're full of it well
factcheck.org is going after President
Trump because President Trump suggests
that hey it's not my fault that these
kids are being separated from their
parents which is true it's not his fault
it's not as well but here's what
factcheck.org writes okay neither the
court settlement nor the 2008 law
require the Trump administration to
break up families they required the
government to release children from
custody after a certain period of
detainment the government absolutely has
the option to release the parents as
well said Sarah Pierce a policy analyst
and migration policy institute that's as
long as they aren't in flight or safety
risk and then they say Trump is lying so
let me explain what that means and let
me explain how stupid that is hey the
what they are saying is that Donald
Trump doesn't have to separate the
parents and the children now you might
ask Shapiro you told us a few minutes
ago that under the law if you want to
retain the parents you do have to
discharge the children somewhere else
right you do so the left is claiming
it's Trump's fault because he's
arresting the parents so if Trump really
didn't want to separate the parents from
the kids he should just let them lose he
does not detain them at all
you understand how insane this is this
is like complaining that children in the
United States are being separated from
felon parents because we arrest the
felon parents and they say well do you
want the kids to go with and I'm like no
but you could release the felon parents
the whole point is that Trump is
enforcing the border now the only thing
that Trump is doing differently than
Obama is he's romancing more cases to
custody than President Obama's and Obama
was fine with letting illegal immigrants
roam into the country he briefly
arrested and then be released into the
general population Trump is not but
under the law if he keeps the parents he
has to release the kids okay now here's
the thing if Democrats wanted to solve
this they could solve this tomorrow they
could solve this tomorrow they could
change the law and they could change the
law to say that when illegal immigrants
come into the country
with the children that there is an
exception to this court ruling they
could overrule the judicial branch
because the judicial branch is
interpreting a settlement agreement
they're not interpreting a Constitution
okay just legally speaking when they say
that the settlement says X all the
government has to do is pass a law
saying that is not what the settlement
says the government this helmet never
said that in fact the government right
now that the legislature could overrule
the judiciary simply by taking away
their capacity to review the situation
that is an ability of Congress under
article 1 of the Constitution is to
limit federal jurisdiction but they're
not doing any of that
instead Democrats are complaining about
all of this because it's more important
to complain about all of this and
pretend that Donald Trump is evil than
it is to actually solve the problems for
a lot of these kids okay so in just a
second I want to talk a little bit about
some more insanity from the left on this
particular topic first I want to say
thank you to our sponsors over at genja
cells so you have those bags under your
eyes so I get bags under my eyes when I
do not sleep properly and this is true
for a lot of people bags and puffiness
under the eyes they're a problem for
millions of American men and women but
there's something called genu cell serum
it has plant stem cell technology from
Shama knee bending this serum since like
my days doing a radio show in Seattle
spent four or five years Susan from New
Jersey writes I've been using Jane
yourself for a couple of months the
puffiness around my eyes is gone even
the crow's feet small lines they've
disappeared they haven't come back I
love the product I use it under my eyes
around my cheekbones on my eyelids when
it comes to our house my mom actually
creeps into the house and steals it and
takes it home to the great irritation of
my wife but genu cell is fantastic and
again I've been using it it's great and
they have instant effects so you see
results in the first 12 hours or your
money back or your money back
they guarantee it right so if you don't
like it just send it back and for a
limited time you can order Jen you sell
and try Shama knees brand new Jen you
sell eyelid lift for droopy sagging
eyelids absolutely free call 866 320 904
that's 800 663 2904 or visit Jen you
Cellcom that's G en you see e l comm
Jenny Cellcom call now and Express
shipping is also free that's Jen you
sell calm Jen you sell calm or 800 663
2904 806 630 2904 Jenny sells a really
fantastic product Germany makes great
stuff so go check them out right now
okay
so how crazy are the media overall this
is not just that they're going after
Ivanka Trump
April Ryan you know she's on CNN all the
time because she's a political analyst
over there and she's always complaining
about how she's being victimized by the
Trump administration she's also a
reporter for American urban radio
networks I believe while she shared an
article on her Twitter account on Sunday
floating the idea that President Trump
could be running a child sex trafficking
ring no joke
paid the tot the article was titled
April Ryan CNN contributor tweets the
sow quote is the Trump administration
running a child trafficking ring or na
follow me down the rabbit hole okay so
she tweets that out
hey why exactly would she tweet that out
well shared with 330,000 or her
followers and Melania Trump's
spokesperson Stephanie Grisham responded
if you're a journalist with many
followers at CNN politics contributor is
it okay to retreat any headline you want
regardless of whether it's true okay a
lot of other people were similarly upset
about April Ryan sweet now I just want
to point something out here pizza gate
was fake I wasn't a real thing there was
a comet ping-pong pizza or whatever the
hell that that pizza shop was called in
Washington DC that was not actually
running a child sex ring out of it and
people who were saying the pizza gate
was real were fooling you okay and
they're ripped by the media the media
said Pizza Gate is fake in the media
we're right Pizza Gate was not real
there was no evidence of child sex
trafficking ring being run out of a
pizza shop in DC Donald Trump is not
running a child sex trafficking ring and
yet April Ryan is not feeling that same
kind of blowback weird isn't that in
that weird she tweets out a piece
suggesting that perhaps Donald Trump is
running a child sex trafficking ring the
President of the United States and
nothing nothing right where's the
blowback on April Ryan
there is no blowback on April Ryan why
because everything is stupid and because
the ear worm that is Donald Trump has
infected the brains of too many folks in
the media okay so I also want to talk
about what's going on at Starbucks in
just a second but for that you're gonna
have to go over to Daily wire comment
and subscribe so for $9.99 a month you
can get a subscription to daily we're
calm comes along with the rest of my
show live the rest of Andrew Clavin show
live the rest of Michael moles is
execrable show live you get all of those
live when you just go over to Daley
we're calm for $9.99 a month also by
buying a subscription you help support
Michael Knowles and I know he's getting
married this upcoming week and frankly
he needs the money because it a certain
point I'm going to fire him so you may
as well get your money and right now so
for $9.99 a month you can get daily
wire.com also for the annual
subscription $99 a year it's cheaper
than the monthly subscription
it also comes along with our fabled
leftist
here's hot or cold tumblr it is so
precious that I actually had to convert
it to invisibility for purposes of this
ad I wasn't going to bring it non
cloaked with me on my journeys it is
right here I know you can't see it but
it does have that capacity or so it is
rumoured I can't guarantee that's how
yours will work that's how mine works
but in any case you can get all of that
when you go over to daily wear comm and
subscribe or check us out later over at
iTunes or YouTube please subscribe but
please leave us a review it always helps
we're the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast in the nation
[Music]
so meanwhile today was the big day at
Starbucks it's the big day at Starbucks
today all racism in the United States
ends it's over
congratulations it's it I know you
thought to yourself but aren't there
still races out there no there aren't
they're all gone
you know how it happened Starbucks shut
down for three hours and talked about
implicit bias it was unbelievable
so you remember just a few weeks ago
there was a grave injustice that was
done at a Starbucks in Philadelphia a
grave horrific injustice there are two
black guys who went into a Starbucks in
Philadelphia and I had my listen one of
several of my listeners go to that
Starbucks the person behind the counter
the manager was a social justice warrior
lady who correct people's pronouns but
it turns out she is secretly on a racist
how do we know she's secretly a racist
we know she's secretly on racists
because they asked to use the restroom
and she said just like I have been asked
before everyone I know a lot of people
when asked if you want to use the
restroom you gotta buy something hey
they said no and she said okay and they
go and they sit down they're sitting
there for a while she says well are you
going to buy something said no we're
waiting for someone and she said well
you probably need to buy something and
they said no and she said well if you
buy you don't buy something I need to
ask you to leave they said no and she
said well if you do um see that I'm
gonna call the police and they said no
and then police came and said well if
you just buy something we don't have to
arrest you think I said no okay and then
they got arrested racism right deep
abiding horrific racism now as I pointed
out at the time I believe there were six
cameras in the Starbucks establishment
six of them okay we still don't have
tape of the entire exchange so we don't
actually know what happened but let's
assume that this woman was a descendant
of Bull Connor and bred in her bones was
hatred of black people for some reason
it had never come out before in
Philadelphia which is like a very very
heavily black City and this particular
Starbucks apparently is in a location
where there are a lot of black patrons
in any case let's assume that the story
is just as good morning America I told
it it was a vicious instance of 1960s
Woolworth counter type discrimination
okay so what what does Starbucks decide
to do they decided we are going to shut
down 8,000 of our stores for three hours
and we're going to give people all sorts
of unconscious bias training now the
thing that unconscious bias is that it's
stupid
the reason it's stupid is because
unconscious bias has no actual
correlation with your behavior so the
suggestion of unconscious biases
you may not act racist you may never
have done anything racist you may not
think you're racist but deep down inside
that teeny-weeny beating heart of yours
lies the heart of a monster deep down in
there you hate black people don't you
and even if you don't you can even if
you say no I don't believe you because
it's unconscious so you don't you
wouldn't even if you hated black people
we wouldn't know about it there's no way
for us to know but we do know because
down deep in your soul you hate black so
this is the whole schtick about
unconscious bias so they give these
implicit assessment bias tests which are
completely flawed they are
scientifically flawed they're not
duplicate they're not repeatable they
make no sense there is no correlation
the people who designed is the implicit
assessment test the implicit bias
assessment test even those people say
that these are not usable in real-world
situations
doesn't matter Starbucks decides they're
gonna mandate that nobody can get coffee
for three hours so we can pretend that
we're doing something about deep abiding
racism at Starbucks so what is this
really designed to do okay so what it's
really designed to do is prevent
litigation against these major
corporations that's really what it's
designed to do so major corporations all
over the country places like Walmart and
Target have undertaken this useless
diversity training to relieve such
unconscious by so let me describe to you
what these Starbucks baristas had to go
through
okay quote is from Yahoo anti-bias
sessions can incorporate personal
reflections explorations of feelings and
mental exercises which is like push-ups
but for your brain one expert says
training of this kind can have the
opposite effect if people feel judged so
it might make them more races so next
time you go into Starbucks maybe they'll
be more ice due knows but we got to do
the training guys because they say we
have to according to a video previewing
the Starbucks training there will be
recorded remarks from Starbucks
executives and rapper and activists
common that's the important part of
common says it we all take it very
seriously I mean it's common sense from
their employees we'll move into a real
and honest exploration of bias where in
small groups they can share how the
issue comes up in their daily work life
then they get out finger paints and
they'll paint with each other it's
really fun and then who trusts Falls and
then at the end of that racism has been
abolished in the United States now
there's no data any of this works
hey Andrew Ferguson writes at The Weekly
Standard quote most recently the Harvard
psychologist Frank Dobbin had counted
his way through more than 800 midsize
and large US companies that had made
diversity training mandatory as
Starbucks is doing Oh
five year period he found no increase in
the percentage of managers who are women
or minorities in fact the number of
black female managers declined more than
nine percent that of Asian men four
point five percent but that data doesn't
actually mean anything because data
doesn't mean anything in these
conversations
he can't even ask for the freaking tape
of these of these actual events you just
have to assume that racism is widespread
unconscious deeply embedded in art in
our DNA as President Obama used to say
and then we're going to Train it out of
you
we're gonna Train it out of you by
paying hundreds of thousands of dollars
to people with no degree in anything who
call themselves diversity trainers
that's how we're gonna fix this now why
do all these corporations do this
because when there are class-action
lawsuits it can cost them a billion
dollars if they lose so instead they
create a settlement with all of these
race baiters and they say ok we will
spend hundreds of thousands of dollars
on diversity training and next time
there's some sort of litigation against
us we go in front of the judge and we
say listen if we were really racist
would we have done diversity training
seriously this is what they do this is
actually part of the policy it is a
litigation strategy by attorneys to
prevent litigation against these major
companies because then they can say
listen that racist thing that person did
outside scope of agency they weren't our
agent they weren't our messengers when
they were doing that they were doing it
on their own because they're just bad
people we're not bad people
we do diversity training we listen to
common and man we love common common is
awesome and that means that no one here
is racist it's a if you think that
Starbucks became one iota less racist if
you thought they're races in the first
place which I do not but if you think
they become one iota less racist because
they took three hours out from making
coffee to talk with each other about
racism you're out of your mind you're
out of your mind but again this is all a
scam it was meant to be a scam they're
barely even hiding the ball on this one
okay meanwhile going through some of the
other news of the day I want to make a
quick point here so that there's been a
lot of talk in the last in the last few
days about Louis Farrakhan so Lewis
Farrakhan who is legitimately one of the
worst human beings in the United States
just an awful awful human being a leader
of the Nation of Islam rabid anti-semite
rabid racist just a piece of human
direct so Louis Farrakhan was on a radio
show and he was talking about President
Trump and Candace Owens tweeted out that
something is happening because Louis
Farrakhan obviously is more warm toward
president more one for President Trump
now this is not me getting a
Candace okay Candace can have her own
opinion on this stuff but I do not think
that this is that was Farrakhan is
saying he's gonna vote for President
Trump and if he did I don't think it
would behoove president Trump to take
his support since as I say Lou's
Farrakhan is a piece of human track here
is Louis Farrakhan supposedly supporting
President Trump Trump is destroying
every enemy that was an enemy of our
rise oh who the enemy of our rise is it
the Department of Justice where we get
none
is it Congress where you make a law that
favors us and then you turn around and
destroy it okay so here's what I would
say about this if Luce Farrakhan is
siding with Donald Trump it should make
you think about some of trumps policies
if was Farrakhan Ranas now I don't think
blues Farrakhan is honest I think as I
say he's a horrible human but what he's
really saying here is that he likes that
Trump is going after the DOJ and the FBI
and he likes that because who's
Farrakhan is sort of in favor of many
criminals so this I'm not really sure
why exactly people would be celebrating
that in any serious way well in other
news Tesla founder Elon Musk has now
been accused of being means of the media
which is a crime in the United States as
we all know so last week
Elon Musk who founded Tesla and SpaceX
he does some pretty cool stuff although
I will acknowledge I'm not a big fan of
the giant giant giant government
subsidies he receives he tweeted out
that the holier-than-thou hypocrisy of
big media companies who lay claim to the
truth but publish only enough to
sugarcoat the lie is why the public no
longer respects them which is true and
then somebody tweeted back at him that
he's that he's like a trump figure he
said thought you'd say that anytime
anyone criticizes the media the media
shrieks you're just like Trump why do
you think he got elected in the first
place because no one believes you
anymore you lost her credibility a long
time ago so Iman musk has been taken to
task by a bunch of people in the media
how dare Elan musk attack the media the
most obvious and stupid piece came
courtesy of a woman in Darren Biba at
The Daily Beast cases she attacked Musk
because she tweeted at him a billionaire
with massive power lashed out at two of
the most under attack industries in the
country
journalism and science both are
essential for democracy first of all
journalism is not an under attack
institution in the United States hey
just because people say they don't trust
the media doesn't mean that journalism
is under attack there's no legislation
against journalism there's no attempt to
quash
journalism thank God that's good and
then she says Elon Musk is an
irresponsible person who doesn't seem to
realize or care about the damage she's
doing our love affair with billionaires
needs to end okay that last sentence
doesn't really seem to follow because
there are lots of different billionaires
in lots of different industries it's a
must tweeted back quote I've never
attacked science definitely attack
misleading journalism like yours though
and then people sent mean tweets to this
lady and she proceeded to write a
full-on piece about how Elan musk was
mean to her and here's what she wrote
musk stweet turned into a singularity of
hate against currently targeted
institutions in our country the musk
bros had a lot of opinions about me
being a woman criticizing their hero and
the maggots that were thrilled that
someone with such a big file one was on
their side against science and
journalism so in other words he says the
media's full of it she says how dare you
attack the media he says you're full of
it and then she proves that she's full
of it that's basically how that that
little colloquy just went and then she
took out a bunch of people from Twitter
who have like 10 followers and blamed
them on Elon Musk which is the new
tactic of a lot of folks on the left and
it's really irritating this tactic where
they suggest that if you have millions
of followers as musk as or if I have or
as many other people have and one of
those followers several of those
followers do something terrible that
somehow our fault no okay if you don't
like what musk says attack what musk
says don't attack must for what his
followers say when he obviously didn't
attempt to push them to do any of this
sort of stuff but the media are no
longer for the truth there are too many
members of the media who are no longer
fur to the truth they're more interested
in propping up their own perception of
self-worth and a lot of that has to do
with this feeling that we are
firefighters and we cannot be attacked
if they accuse president Trump of having
a thin skin or conservatives of having a
thin skin
nobody has thinner skin than some of the
members the mainstream media it's truly
astonishing okay time for a couple of
things that I like and then some things
that I hate so things that I like today
I have been starting a new series on
Netflix I know not the Michelle
what's-her-face wolf series not not her
not her foolish attempts to do Weekend
Update I haven't started that yet I'll
probably I'll probably watch some of
that tonight so I can put it in things I
hate I may be I love it maybe I well I
don't want to prejudge it I have a
feeling it's gonna suck but you know
other things that I like there's a show
called Babylon Berlin that's really good
it's a it's a German series is the most
expensive
ever made in Germany and it takes place
during the let the latter days of the
vitamin Republic and it doesn't really
make any it makes a very oblique
reference to Hitler but it makes very
few references to the Nazis or Hitler it
is just sort of here's the milieu so it
gives you the communist uprising that's
happening and it gives you the roots of
Nazi rage in Germany and it gives you
all of this against the backdrop of
basically a crime show an investigation
of a crime that ties together all of
these disparate strands here's a little
bit of the preview from Netflix that
shows Babylon Berlin I have been told
that our mutual friend is doing business
on the side he's ambitious dogged a
ferret I'll deal with it what happened
here me
so the production values on this thing
are really really high you know
obviously the previews in English but
it's dubbed so if I were you I would
watch it in the original German and with
the subtitles I just think it's it's
less irritating and less distracting but
the show is I'm three episodes in it's
quite good I'll keep you updated if it
turns around in stinks then you'll hear
about it but so far so good okay other
things
okay time you know what let's do some
things I hate so things that I hate so
today they're a bunch of rockets mortars
that were fired into Israel
apparently 50 odd mortars fired into
southern Israel there are a two
terrorists who attempted to cut the
border from the Gaza Strip into Israel
with bolt cutters to get into Israel and
murder children in their beds because
this is what Hamas terrorists do and
Israel has been bombing Gaza Strip so
naturally all the media coverage has
been Israel bombs Gaza Strip very little
of the media coverage has been about the
fact that Hamas precipitated it by
literally putting hundreds of thousands
of people into bunkers right they forced
hundreds of thousands of people into
bunkers in southern Israel and then they
hit a kindergartner a kindergarten with
mortars one of the mortars directly hit
a kindergarten there were no kids in it
thank God but this this is just a
reminder Hamas is a terrorist group
Islamic Jihad is a terrorist group what
happened at the Gaza border two weeks
ago was a terrorist activity it and and
so here's my mock headline for the media
peaceful Palestinian terrorist fire
peaceful mortars at Jewish kindergarten
attempt peaceful murderous border
breaches against Israel because they're
all peaceful don't you know
Hamas is peaceful Islamic Jihad is
peaceful it's been so irritating
watching the media cover all this stuff
when they are being eminently and
obviously dishonest about all of it no
wonder so many like Elon Musk are
looking at the media and saying you guys
don't know what the hell you are doing
meanwhile other things that I hate so
this was pretty terrible yesterday
Chelsea Manning tweeted out pictures of
himself on top of a building so Chelsea
Manning a formerly Bradley Manning
traitor to the United States but
released thanks to a thanks to a
commutation of sentence did he get fully
pardoned by Obama I believe he was calm
I think his sentence was commuted he
wasn't fully pardoned but he tweeted out
a picture of a top from the top of the
building and to I'm sorry I tried and it
basically a suicide note as it appeared
on Twitter and the N Chelsea Manning I
hope really really does get some help
you know Chelsea Manning is still as
much I despise what Chelsea Manning did
as far as being a traitor and as much as
I disagree with Chelsea Manning about
politics if you need help get help like
if you need help get help
suicide is not the answer even for
people with whom I disagree politically
okay we were we're all children of God
even people who I think have done
despicable things in the past Chelsea
Manning apparently is getting help so
thank God for that but we all ought to
be praying for people who are under the
suicidal impulse because obviously
that's something very hard okay time for
a final thing that I hate so a president
Trump you know he celebrated memorial
take yesterday in a couple of ways one
was good one was bad it was ultimate
good Trump bad Trump so good Trump was
he he gave a speech all about Memorial
Day he put up some clips from that
speech I believe it was in front of an
Naval grad audience and he he put up
some clips of that on Twitter that was
great then he also put up this tweet
which was not so great so he tweeted out
happy Memorial Day those who died for a
great country would be very happy and
proud of how well our country is doing
today best economy in decades lowest
unemployment numbers for blacks and
Hispanics ever and women in 18 years
rebuilding our military and so much more
nice ah no wrong you did it wrong mr.
president this is not a good tweet hey
Barack Obama had a really bad habit his
bad habit was no matter what was
happening in the world
there's Memorial Day he would then tweet
out a picture of himself like Adam
Memorial Day ceremony he wouldn't weed
out pictures of soldiers or something he
would tweet out pictures of him because
Barack Obama was the most important
person in the universe well Donald Trump
seems to be following in those footsteps
except worse in this particular tweet
the idea that these troops would be very
happy and proud of how our country is
doing today because he's done such a
great job in office so all of these
slain troops would be big fans like
that's not what the day is for and I
think that he realized that later and
then tweeted out some more appropriate
feelings but this is why when when some
people like me say he might want to cut
back on the Twitter this is an example
of why the president might want to cut
back on the Twitter because let's be
real about this if this had been Hillary
Clinton tweeting this out I would be all
over that I would be screaming at her I
would have spent 15 minutes on the show
about that okay what Donald Trump did in
this tweet is really quite gross you are
not allowed to tout your own
accomplishments in office in a tweet
honoring slain soldiers that's just not
something you can do it's not something
that is appropriate it's not something
that is
and that tweet is not appropriate or
decent again he put another tweet that
was quite appropriate and quite decent
but this one was not OK
so we'll be back here tomorrow with all
of the latest to top North Korean
official is apparently visiting the
United States love all the updates on
what goes on there I'm Ben Shapiro this
is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Sonia Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Alex and Garo
Audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Jess wah of era the Ben
Shapiro show is a daily wire Ford
publishing production copyright Ford
publishing 2018